قال سيدنا لا علاقه لها بالحادث او
بالحادث التي حصلت في بولندا كريم ندى بما
اسماء هستيريا من طرف مسؤولينا كبار لدول
عده ما اخر ما ورد في التصريحات وزاره
الدفاع حول هذه الضربات يعني
[موسيقى]
عمليات القصر الروسيه همم كانت تبعد عن
الحدود الهولنديه الاوكرانيه نحو 35 كلم
من المعروف انه بالامس كان هناك قصف جوي
قامت به مقاتلات الروسيه على مناطق مدينه
الريف والامر الذي ادى الى غرقت المدينه
في ظلام الدامس ويتوقفت محطه فيها عن
العمل همم لذلك انك عديد من الخبراء الذين
همم اعتبروا ان الشيطان الصواريخ الذي
نشرت له صوره في شركات تواصل الاجتماعي او
بشكل عام همم الا صواريخ اطلقتها منظومه
الدفاع الجوي الاكرانيه هو ضل الطريقها ان
توجه بشكل صائب وبالتالي اصابت مناطق في
الاراضي البولنديه همم موسكو يعتبرت ان
هذه الخطوه او هذه التصريحات التي جاءت
باتهامها بالتورن في تفجيرات شرح هولندا
هي محاوله لتصعيد الموقف بل ان البعض بعض
السياسيين وتحديدا من البرلمان الروسي ذهب
الى ان القوات الاوكرانيه تحاول استفزاز
الغرب والدول الميتو للدخول في مواجهات
عسكريه مع روسيا استنادا الى هذه الامه
شكرا لك مازن عباس مراسل فروزن في موسكو